cette histoire là c'est l'histoire que
j'ai vu que quand je suis arrivé en
france à l'âge de sept ans et demi je
voyage de séoul
en france j'étais riz à l'aéroport
charles de gaulle 9 heures d'avion pas
faim je sais pas parler français je
comprends rien je vois la pomme et que
c'était le seul produit que j'oppose
égyptiens je suis content enfin un
produit que je connais et que j'ai
croqué dans cette pomme là je me dis
bien un problème parce que les pommes
coréenne en tout l'aspect visuel d'une
pomme française mais lorsqu on croque en
gouttes
j'ai compris sans parler français que
j'étais dans le pays parce que le goût
est totalement différente
bonjour je m'appelle pierre sang-soo
chef de cuisine et je vais vous parler
d'un plat qui me tient à coeur le be bop
le kimchi c'est c'est l'ingrédient qui
est métaphore de ma vie lorsqu'on
connaît mal un produit ou un manque
d'information vous savez en ce sens et
ce qui me tue la messe à vous faire
monter et ont toujours travaillé dans
des restaurants français
on n'a pas l'habitude ça pour prix de ce
goût là quoi j'avais que 21 ans quand je
suis retourné en cours et si je t'ai pas
prêt première claque si jamais mangé
dans un récent coréen avant je vis à la
campagne le kimchi c'est le légume
nationale qu'on fait là-bas c'est un peu
comme notre baguette beurre on va dire
une condition c'est m arrivait dans du
gros sel après fermenté avec du piment
de live est un peu de soi sans choix et
une base de purée de riz
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal au début parce
que tout le monde parlait du kimchi team
chine et la corée et c'est là où je me
suis rendu compte que j'étais vraiment
français parce que le goût j'ai beaucoup
de mal avec ce goût fermenté et au fur
et à mesure j'ai appris à l'apprivoiser
on va dire ce goût là et surtout je me
suis rendu compte qu'une partie de moi
ma mentalité
mon caractère et elle accourt et que
j'ai toujours voulu ignorer en treillis
[Musique]
laurie du vimpat et un peu spécial chez
moi rajoute la lentille verte du puy un
produit que j'affectionne au moins parce
que j'ai grandi au tour de chant des
lentilles
là je suis une technique un peu
asiatiques vous voyez c'est à dire le
frud rice lors il a été tout simplement
pour les jets étaient adoptées en
auvergne exactement en haute-loire à
lantriac et dans cette région là on
produit beaucoup de lentille verte du
puy pour moi le goût de lentilles de ma
grand mère c'est toujours la lentille
qui était cuit avec dans un bouillon
avec beaucoup de beurre une pointe d'ail
du thym du laurier est un peu de persil
là vous avez dans la poêle au niveau des
odeurs toutes mes envies mes souvenirs
mon enfance ce qui me guide c'est
quelque chose que j'ai envie de partager
avec un plus grand nombre est là pour
rappeler mais notre enfance je vais
rajouter la verveine verte du puy donc
la verveine c'est une plante verte
cotisent pour pour faire des infusions
des 10 des digestifs et là je veux que
dans l'assiette les gens retrouvent tous
les éléments qui représente mon univers
c'est à dire mes racines mes voyages
ce plat là m'a permis de me faire
connaître parce que c'est un plat qui a
voyagé qui vient d'un pays lointain la
corée mais qu'avec des produits d'ici et
par rapport à mon histoire j'ai toujours
voulu le rendre accessible dans
l'assiette aujourd'hui j'ai mis que des
choses de producteurs locaux bio qui
font très attention à la nature et on
oublie souvent la nature mais c'est
grâce à la nature que je fais mon métier
de cuisinier aujourd'hui